thanks guys thank you very much Andy
nice to see you wouldn't see you thanks
you have a good weekend yeah pretty good
mm-hmm stayed inside stayed inside in
New York a lot of New Yorkers do that
yes coward in the corner of my apartment
looked out the window occasional Andy I
had a big weekend really yeah I went
down to Memphis Tennessee this weekend
and I brought an audience with me no I
went to Memphis Tennessee to actually
fulfill a dream that I've that I've
always had I don't know why you're
laughing at that he would have a dream
to fulfill no I actually I it was a I
went on a mission this weekend a mission
to Memphis it meant a great deal to me
and well I filmed it so I think it the
story tells itself ladies and gentlemen
my story in Memphis enjoy hi I'm
standing in front of the legendary Sun
Studio right here in downtown Memphis
and I came here because I wanted to
record a song about being a talk-show
host some of the pain that's involved
and I think I'm ready to go I thought
before I went in there though maybe I'd
stop off at this cafe right here and
well write the song I haven't done that
yet
[Laughter]
[Music]
like anything to eat no thanks I'm fine
what's your knot huh you want to get me
some food yeah
no it's okay really I'm fine
[Music]
you have any waffles I want to write a
song I wanted to write a song that
talked a little bit about the pain of
being a talk-show host you mean people
see the fun part they see laughing but
they don't see the other side
imagine me talking to a woman on the
show say Suzanne Somers I go blah she
goes blah we go blah blah blah blah
yackety-yak then there's a chord change
on my show blah-dee-blah
I asked her a question and she answers
me back
well I sit behind the desk and she sits
next to me I flap my gums but does she
really hear me huh she nods and smiles
and she shows her clips but will she
ever kiss my lonesome lips here's the
part that's really sad I'm just another
lonely talk-show host
trying to get through to a guest though
Andy's always there for me my real
sidekicks called loneliness it's good
scale of 1 to 10
[Applause]
what's the blah blah blah
do with it you don't like the blah blah
blah part what's wrong with it
it just doesn't say anything nothing at
all that's the whole point is that
people talking but they're not really
saying anything that's what I'm trying
to that's right yeah great you disagree
with him well yeah I believe people can
talk okay so you two completely disagree
you're gonna have a fight now but you
think it's got a chance to being a big
hit
I wouldn't say that okay I'm here with
Garry Hardy who's the owner of Sun
Studios Gary good to see ya how you
doing thank you for letting me in here
I'm gonna put you over in the spot I
mean the spot the e spot the e spot this
is where Elvis actually recorded his
first song yeah I'm pretty sure show me
the exact spot
I'm pretty sure this is it I'm pretty
serious for like right you think you
think it's right like right here like
right here
yeah right like we're worried he okay
but I can't put my feet exactly there
that's it that's it that's it
all right so oh okay so now we're my
feet are now this foot a little but
there you go that's it he went this is
very he had like a weird posture
[Music]
alright guys I think we're getting it
looks so let's try it one more time
all right
[Music]
[Applause]
okay well anyway now I'm here at a
record store
I've actually we've had the the
recording made into a CD I get a shot of
that I'm pretty excited about it
okay we're gonna go inside and we're
gonna try and I don't know
get this thing selling who would I talk
to I got a CD that I'm just coming out
with who do I talk to about getting
these on the shelves talk to the owner
talk to the owner listen what I'd like
you to do is maybe play the song on your
PA system and so the whole story here is
it and then I think we're probably going
to see a rush to buy this to be don't
you think thank you very much
[Music]
it's late night cowboy I mean do you
like the picture of me on the cover I
guess so I think I do you think I do you
think I look happy or what would you say
I look like what's that expression say -
you really look kind of weird it looks
weird in the head you away yeah I think
the hat looks funny I thought that's
what people wore is this how people
dress around here cuz I don't know I
thought this is what people were into
and I I've noticed that I'm the only one
dressed like this here yeah I noticed
that too we have a special guest in the
studio from New York City NBC television
ladies and gentlemen Conan O'Brien this
is right this is it I got it right here
it's it's a little disc called
late-night cowboy and I've got the
that's the a side the B side is uh
we didn't I didn't have another song so
we just recorded stairway to heaven all
right remember it's all about the pain
and loneliness of being a talk show host
talking to a woman guest out there
that's about all right this is the world
premiere of late-night cowboy Conan
O'Brien on FM 100 get here in Memphis
Tennessee
[Music]
local records here I'm sure I'll have
that for you and very special thanks to
WMS CTV the Memphis affiliate kind
enough to let us film down there ladies
and gentlemen we'll be right back with
Nancy Kerrigan don't go nowhere